It was Christmas time in Camelot
and King Arthur was throwing a party.
The entire court was invited—
save the wicked sorceress Morgan le Fay—
and food and drink flowed freely.
But in the midst of the revelry,
the castle doors split open.
A towering knight riding an emerald
steed burst into the room,
stunning the court into silence.
Then, in a deep bellowing voice,
he proposed a game.
The Green Knight declared he would allow
the bravest warrior present to attack him
with his own axe.
If they could strike him down,
they would win his powerful weapon.
However, the knight would be allowed
to return that blow
in one year and one day.
Arthur and his knights were baffled.
No man could survive such a strike.
The Green Knight began to mock
their leader’s hesitance,
and Arthur stood to defend his honor.
But as soon as he gripped the axe,
another leapt to take his place.
Arthur’s nephew, Sir Gawain,
took the weapon instead.
And with one swift strike, he beheaded
the grinning knight.
But the moment his skull met the ground,
it began to laugh.
The Green Knight collected his head
and mounted his horse.
As he rode off, his severed head
reminded Gawain of their contract
and told him to seek the Green Chapel
one year hence.
In the months that followed, Gawain tried
to forget this bizarre vision.
But despite the strangeness
of the knight’s game,
he was determined to act honorably.
When the following winter approached,
he set out—
enduring foul weather
and beastly encounters
in his quest to find
the mysterious Green Chapel.
Finally, on Christmas Eve, he saw
a shimmering castle on the horizon.
The castle’s lord and lady were thrilled
to help such an honorable guest,
and informed him that the Green Chapel
was only a short ride away.
They implored Gawain to rest at their home
until his meeting with the Green Knight.
Thrilled at this news, Gawain happily
accepted their offer.
However, in exchange
for their hospitality,
the lord made a strange request.
Over the next three days, he would go
hunting and share his spoils every night.
In return, Gawain must give him whatever
he’d gained during his day at the castle.
At first, Gawain was perplexed
by these strange terms.
But the lord’s meaning became quite clear
the next day,
when his wife tried to seduce Gawain.
To rebuff the lady’s advances
without offending her honor,
Gawain allowed one kiss—
which he then passed on to her husband
in exchange for a slain dear.
The next day, Gawain allowed two kisses,
which he gave to the lord for a dead boar.
But on the third day, the lady offered
more than just three kisses.
She presented a magical sash
that would protect Gawain
from the Green Knight’s blade.
Gawain accepted immediately,
but that evening, when the lord returned,
the knight offered only three kisses
with no mention of his enchanted gift.
The next morning, Gawain rode
out to the Green Chapel—
a simple mound of earth
where the Green Knight
ominously sharpened an axe.
With the sash’s protection,
Gawain approached stoically—
determined to honor his agreement.
He bowed his head for the deadly blow,
and with a massive swing,
the Green Knight cut Gawain’s neck—
inflicting nothing more
than a flesh wound.
Once more, Gawain was bewildered.
Why hadn’t the sash protected him?
And why hadn’t the knight
killed him?
Bursting into laughter, the Green Knight
revealed himself to be the castle’s lord,
and he’d been working with Morgan Le Fay
to test the honor and bravery
of Arthur’s knights.
He was impressed with Gawain’s behavior,
and he’d planned to spare
his neck entirely—
until Gawain concealed the sash.
Filled with shame,
Gawain returned to Camelot.
But to his surprise,
his companions absolved him of blame
and celebrated his valor.
Struggling to understand
this strange journey,
it seemed to Gawain that perhaps
the whole world was playing a game—
with rules more wild and bewildering
than any man could understand.